maana
room he tells us this hadith he works on it
and he has a poem called the man who looked back
while on his way to the fire and he's basing this on this hadith
so he says the guardian angels
who used to walk unseen before him and behind him
have now become visible and they drive him to the like prison guards,
which is true. How many angels do you live with?
You have, you have, they're here or here, wherever they may be.
They are there. You never saw them.
You have other angels that are with you constantly
that protect you, that help you, that do other things for you.
Over a hundred,
okay? But you don't see them.
And we don't even pay attention to them.
We forget about them totally.
We must never disbelieve in them because that would be kufur.
But on the day of judgment, you will see them.
When you die, your two angels and sit at your grave
and they ask God to forgive you.
Okay? And they will be res when you're resurrected, they will be there, too.
So these people now see their angels who lived out the miserable lives of these two
men as they disobeyed God and they did terrible things.
Now they've become like policemen who drive them to the fire.
So you didn't believe in us.
Okay. Well, let's see if you believe in us now.
And then one of them looks back wistfully.
Jalaladin Molana. He says his tears fall from his eyes like the soft rain of autumn
before the winter. The rain that's not going to grow anything cuz the summer's over.
Just a mere hope,
a tear.
What does he have but that?
And then in the hadith it says God sends the angels to say why did he
look back?
So
also tells us that and then the man says, "God, my lord,
I am a hundred times a hundred times worse
than you declared me to be at my judgment.
I deserve nothing but the fire.
But I had in this wretched heart
a hope that never died, that somehow you would show me your loving kindness.
I turn to you.
He's speaking. That's why it's about words.
I turn to you and to your pure grace, not to my actions.
I trust in you, not in me.
I'm nothing. So then God tells the angels, "Bring him back.
Forgive him. Put him in the garden.
He never lost hope in me, even as he walks to the fire."
It's a beautiful story.
very meaningful story. And we know that the believers who go to the fire, may we
not be among them.
And they are a lot.
They are hordes of believers because most believers never figure it out.
They live their lives in
neglect and heedfulness.
But the believer will be released
from the fire. and you will wish and may you never go that you had never
gone. May we not go there.
May we realize what this dean is about and wake up while we are here is
um but nevertheless um you know this man is among the first who will be released
from that and he didn't even go in but he had that hope.
So uh the tongue then is an amazing thing and use it as that amazing thing
that it is and it's also very dangerous.
Um
the tongue is so easy to use right
almost every one of us some people speak more easily than others.
Some have great facility, others don't have the same facility.
But we can all use our tongues generally speaking, unless there's some obstruction
and the tongue is small in size.
It's easy to use, especially if you're speaking your mother tongue.
Um,
you know, so we usually use our tongues without thinking about what we're doing.
And that's a very disastrous thing to do.
Therefore, as a rule,
our tongues are the most disobedient
of all the human faculties that we have.
They rattle on. They paddle on.
They never get tired.
You know, they they rush in where angels fear to tread.
This is because the the tongue is so easy to use, so easy to unleash.
And often, especially when we're not talking about what's good, we don't get tired of talking.
It costs so little for us to keep it working, the tongue.
And therefore, most human beings give it no attention.
They pay it no attention.
We take lightly whatever we say and therefore the tongue is Satan's
most successful ploy
to use against us in guiding us astray.
The prophet said saiam.
So the blessed prophet said sallallahu alaihi wasallam
the servant of gods
iman
will not be
right
won't be the way it's supposed to be won't be straight it won't be sound
until his or her heart
is right
is sound
and his or her heart will not be right or sound until the tongue is sound,
until the tongue is right.
So, you've got to get that straight.
And this is one of the most important things for you.
No doubt you do that already, but you want to do it all the time.
Think about what you are speaking about.
Be careful about what you say.
There is safety in silence.
Wrong speech hurts you.
Wrong speech weighs you down.
Bad speech harms your heart and it also chips away at your iman.
Even though the words that you speak seem to be as light as feathers,
they seem to depear
in thin air, but they don't.
That's not the way reality is set up.
you need to learn about the metaphysics
of this world. The way this world is really put together.
Um
so uh speech is very very important
and um too much talk
fills your heart with worries.
That's the least it does.
You have worries. One of the best way that you ways that you can overcome your
worries is silence.
Invoke the name of God.
Recite the Quran.
Sit and be silent.
Think about God. Think about the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam.
But when you talk and talk and talk and talk and talk and talk and talk
and call up this person and Twitter that person and text this person, your heart becomes
filled with trouble
and worries.
And of course, there are times when you have to talk.
There are times when you have to tell others about the misery that you may feel
and the situation that you're in.
But you pick those people carefully and you pick your words carefully.
Okay, don't think that you can remove your troubles and your anxieties by just talking and
talking and talking.
Tawus,
his name means the peacock and he was one of the greatest of the successors.
May Allah be pleased with them all.
And he was from the Yemen.
The Yemen is a beautiful part of the world.
May God protect it in this time of horrible calamities
and
disasters that is sweeping the world everywhere.
The Tu said, "My tongue is a wild beast sever.
If I were to let it loose, it would eat me alive."
Are those beautiful words?
Those are the words of a of Allah.
Look how few they are.
But they are worth saying a thousand times.
Abdullahbn Mass, may Allah be pleased with him,
he said, "Nothing
is more deserving
of a long prison sentence
than your tongue.
You need to put your tongue in prison for a long time.
So do I.
It deserves that. Be careful about what you say.
Maana Abu Bakr is
the greatest of all human beings after the prophets and the messengers.
What did he used to do?
He kept a pebble on his tongue.
What a silly thing to do.
No,
you could buy here in Turkey a precious stone.
Right here in the market in Ca.
could get a tiger's eye or something else, polish it and put it on your tongue
and then when you want to speak, you can't talk.
You have to go, "Well, just a minute."
But before you do that, think
may Allah be pleased with him.
He did that so he cannot speak
without thinking.
He's got to listen to you carefully.
There's a pebble in his mouth.
I wish I had that pebble.
It must be very blessed.
And then before he speaks, he takes it out.
Okay? And this is the itchi
of one of the greatest human beings who ever was.
So that what he speaks is right.
Let's go back to the peacock,
great successor, great,
great of Allah.
He says,
So he said he we can say she as well in Arabic whenever we use the
male gender we always imply the female.
If we say brother we mean sister.
If we say brotherhood we mean sisterhood and our fukah talk about that.
Unless we mean to say something specifically related to one gender or another then we specify
that.
But he says that he or she has no sound intellectual
understanding of the dean who does not guard
his or her tongue.
So
when we just talk as most of us do and most of our brothers and sisters
do often raising our voices right then it means that we don't have much intellect
and we have no intellectual understanding of the dean we haven't grasped it so may we
grasp it
may Allah be pleased with him who was one of the greatest of the successors
He's really the master you know of the successors along with Parani who's sort of between
the companions and the successors
but he said they meaning the companions and the successors
and this is also a hadith
they used to say
the tongue of the believer is behind his heart.
The tongue of the believer is behind his heart or her heart.
If he wants to say something, he reflects on it in his heart
and then if it's good, his heart lets him say it.
Go ahead and speak.
It's okay.
But the tongue of the hypocrite,
he that's and this is often what they do.
They they compare the believer with the hypocrite.
Who was the great believer in Medina?
The one who prayed all night.
The one who fasted every other day.
The one who recited the Quran day and night.
Most of them did that.
But it's the one who met his brother with joy on his face and a smile
and no duplicity in his heart and no hypocrisy.
And they believed that the the frowning Muslim who can never smile, who's never really happy
with his brothers and sisters, has the stamp of hypocrisy on his face?
How many Muslims are like that today?
They don't smile. They frown.
They're not happy to see anyone.
They have a bad opinion of everyone.
A lot of them believe that we are Muslims for sure.
But I don't know about the rest of these people.
They all sayahillah.
They all say Muhammad.
If God is content to create weak people as his servants
who have failings whom he will guide and forgive.
You're not content to be their brother.
You're not content to be their sister.
If you can't serve the people that God created
and love them,
you think you can serve God.
That doesn't work like that.
It doesn't work like that.
And this is why for the Sahabah to have a clean heart, a good heart,
a heart that is filled with joy
at the believer,
whether that believer is the best or the worst.
and to help the person who needs to be helped.
You know, this is the sign of belief.
But the believer's tongue is behind his or her heart.
The hypocrites tongue is in front of his heart.
This is what Alassi said.
This is what the companions believed.
Who taught them? The prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam.
If he is concerned about anything or bothered by anything or perplexed by anything, he blurts
it out.
His tongue just says it
and he does not use his or her heart to reflect on it.
Okay, this is the way politicians are.
That's why they did I really say that well well um you know I mean if
you speak the truth you don't have to worry about what you said.
you know, if you will put your tongue behind your heart, you don't have to worry
about what you said, but they're not like that.
So, may Allah enable us, you know, to um follow this guidance.
Thank you.
Um so then we begin to speak a little bit about the secrets of silence
because silence is your friend.
Silence is your gift
and speech must come out of silence.
And when silence is the way it should be filled with reflection
filled with thought silence pollinates your intellect.
And then silence gives you beautiful speech.
Silence is golden.
Speech is silver.
Silence is
gathering.
Speech is
separation.
Speech silence is power.
Speech is weakness.
Doesn't mean that it's going to always be weak.
And it doesn't mean that it's always going to be silver.
Might be gold, but it's got to come out of silence.
How could Alassi
think of these things to say?
How could Paw think of these things to say?
How could Abdullahbas
think of these things to say?
Because they live in a world of silence that pollinates their intellects.
They think about things and they speak little.
And then when they speak that speech is worth recording until the day of judgment.
The prophet said,
"Whoever keeps silence will be safe.
Whoever keeps silence will be safe.
You will succeed.
So learn to be silent."
And again, we live in the world of plastic words.
We live under the rain
of plastic words.
No denotations,
a thousand connotations.
They change like styles.
Okay? And we talk and we talk and we talk.
The talk show. We say whatever we want.
We text,
you know, we Twitter.
Okay? So you have got to learn to bring this under control and then your intellect
will grow
and you will understand your religion with your heart and your intellect.
And this is not stupid silence.
This is the silence of men and women who have oceans in their hearts.
The prophet said, "Sallam
Whoever would be
made happy, filled with joy to be safe on the day of judgment and in this
world as well. Let him keep silence.
So you've got to learn to do this.
And again in our cultures it's often difficult because especially in some of our cultures like
that of many Americans
if you don't talk they think you don't like them.
In fact they think that you dislike them and that you
want to hurt them.
You know um this is just the way their culture is.
They're not all like that.
But the thing is this is why also you have to learn another prophetic sunnah which
no doubt you do.
Smile
and let that smile radiate the beauty of your heart
because the smile also speaks for you without saying words.
So I do like you.
I like to be in your presence.
You do have value to me but I don't have a lot of things to say.
And uh we need to do be able to reduce speech.
Often even if we're driving in the car together and you're silent and he's silent and
the other person's silent, it's like what's wrong?
You know, who's going to break the ice?
Well, there's no ice.
Maybe we're all doing,
you know, and in the traditional Muslim world, there would be no problem with that whatsoever.
But for us, it puts us on edge because we live in this word, this world
where we diffuse
the problems we have, the anxieties we have by meaningless speech.
Go, have you ever been to a club, an athletic club, YMCA,
whatever it is, and listen to how the people talk.
Usually, they're just diusing
their anxieties. They're not saying anything.
So,
um, the prophet said, "Sallam,
he said, peace be upon him, shall I not inform you
about the easiest type of worship?"
I'd like to know that.
The easiest type of worship.
How long did you stand in Ramadan?
Did your feet hurt?
Yes. Did your legs hurt?
Yes. Did you get tired?
Of course you did.
So did I.
We're not supposed to be like that, but we're weak.
Is there an easier type of worship?
We'll also do that one.
So he said, "Can I let me tell you about the easiest form of worship
and the most convenient for the body?
Keeping silence.
Not hard to do.
Keeping silence as an act of worship and having good character.
Deal with the people, all people,
whoever they are, with good character.
What a beautiful thing to do.
The prophet said,
the prophet said, sallallahu alaihi wasallam, whoever believes in God in the last day, you believe
in God, you believe in the last day.
It's real.
When is the last day going to be?
What are the signs of the day of judgment?
Well, that's important.
When is your last day?
When is your day of judgment?
That's practical.
Whether we are round to see the final hour or not, not too likely
and not extremely important.
But I have a last day that is coming and so do you.
That's what counts.
Don't forget that. Don't forget that.
It could be the next five minutes.
It could be tomorrow.
And it doesn't matter how old you are or young.
not even how healthy you might be.
Okay, so that's what counts.
We believe in the last day.
And whoever believes in God in the last day,
then let him speak good or keep quiet or be quiet.
Prophet said,
"Oh,
may God show special mercy to a person, a servant of God who speaks and wins
great bounty like Maana."
Okay.
Um or the zakar, the person who invokes God
or the person who recites the Quran
or who keeps silence and is safe.
The sal
may Allah be pleased with them and make us pleased with them and let us benefit
from them. of all the things the upright Muslims of the first generations
cared about.
Was it giving fatwa?
Was it giving fat?
Was it saying this is haram?
This is haram. This is this is No, that was about two dozen of them that
did that.
And they regarded it to be an affliction that they had to bear because somebody's got
to clarify the law.
you know she's one of those Abdullahb is another Omar is another
is another and there are others okay but most of them they don't want to talk
about that because they don't want to be judged
but they all know about the heart
they all every single one of them knew about the heart and this is something I
im gazali
makes really clear throughout the whole of the which is one of the greatest treasure measures
that God has left for human beings.
They are people who cared about their hearts.
But they would say
silence s keeping silence brings together for you two excellent traits.
Salama in your dean
soundness and safety in your religion and the ability to understand your companion.
You know it's very important to understand your brother or your sister.
That is one of your obligations.
This religion is sincere
behavior towards others. Counsel.
How can you give counsel to people you don't understand?
How can you give counsel to people you don't know?
If we learn to be quiet, then we begin to learn.
Listen to what they say.
Listen to what they have to say.
Don't be ready to talk and talk when the time comes to talk.
So this is also one of the gifts of the secrets of silence.
You begin to understand other people.
You begin to have compassion for them and empathy with them.
And solitude also helps us to do that.
And you should always have a time of solitude.
Even if you're a housewife who has many children and many responsibilities,
you need a time for yourself when you are silent
and when you can just be quiet.
So silence also enables us to develop this trait of silence.
Solitude, I'm sorry, solitude.
And this is the kind of silent silence that pollinates your intellect
and purifies your heart and removes your troubles and removes your anxieties and gives you dignity.
War
is an incredible quality that you have in you because of that precious good that is
in you that you've got locked in a safe place
and it enables you to teach and to live tawa the fear of God and the
consciousness of God. Let's end here with um a beautiful statement from the great Khaled Abd
Aziz. May Allah be merciful to him.
And when Omar died, a sui tells us that when they buried Omarbd Aziz in Damascus,
they saw a piece of paper
up in the air going back and forth and it came down and down and down
and down until it settled on his grave.
And they picked it up and it says,
"You are free of the fire.
You are free of the fire.
Aziz was one of the greatest of all and again this is a letter he wrote
to ali
to Imam Malik
you know to Abu Hanifh and to uh you know the other great jurists of his
time
um Abuhanifh received this letter Alah received it and many others alasim Iban Muhammad and others
so he wrote to them his letter is two lines
and he said As for what follows,
whoever calls death to mind frequently
will be content with little in this world.
Im Shafi, may Allah be pleased with him, is one of the greatest of the great.
Immafi
once went into a situation in Medina
where
500 questions about
involuntary manslaughter
were brought to him
and he answered them all.
And then he was given gifts from the people of Korasan and the gifts from the
people of Iraq and others.
And um he began to cry.
And in one story they say Imam Malik was there and he said why are you
crying? They said it's because of fear of the world isn't it?
And Imam Ashafi said yes I did this for the sake of God and they give
me this treasure in place of it.
Who will protect my heart?
And of course I im Malikaf Abu Hanifh Ahmed Hanbal may Allah be pleased with them.
They attain the heights they did because they can keep that world out of their hearts.
But he sends this to people like them
because the in particular
he or she has got to beware of the world.
So he says call death to mind all the time and then you'll be happy with
little and you'll be able to give away what you were given.
Then he says whoever regards his speech
to be part of his action,
we might say voluntary action.
In other words, this is that's what your speech is.
It's a voluntary act.
It's a speech act.
When you stood up to pray in Ramadan and you knew that was a voluntary act
and you did it because you believed in God and you did it because you wanted
his reward and you knew it's hard,
but I'll do it every night.
And it gets easier.
Okay? And we want to listen to the whole Quran.
It's not easy. We know that's an act.
I chose to do that act.
It's voluntary
just like giving in charity, going to Umrah, going to pilgrimage.
So these things we do, we know these are acts.
We're very careful. So he said never forget that your speech is also a voluntary act.
And he says when you know that then your speech will be little
except for what concerns you.
And they say that vikar the invocation of god is the fasting of the tongue
you know. So if you don't have a pebble and even if you have a pebble
you can take it out and you can do vikar invocation
the remembrance of god invoking.
You have the power to call upon the name of god.
What a special person you are.
And god will mention you in the seventh heaven.
Okay. And again, who are you?
Son of Adam, daughter of Adam.
You know, you have got to learn who you are and you've got to live for
that and you've got to realize that.
And if you do that, you change the world.
You change the world.
So, um I think our time might be up.
Yep. It is. It is time up.
Okay. So, we've got these little questions and I will take them with me and uh
I think we have a session tomorrow
and maybe the next day we have two and we have another day that will also
be two. I think we have nine in all and uh inshallah we'll try to make
good use of it.
I hope we have time for questions and I'll try to look at these and um
inshallah Allah bless you and protect you.
Amen. Amen. Amen.
Um, it's a great honor to be in this city and it's an especially great honor
to be in this city with people like you and may Allah make these blessed days
and
um, you know, may this be one of the great transformations of our lives.
You know that um, we have a lot of work to do.
Okay. You know, you live in a time the last 200 years everything was done to
destroy this religion that is thinkable and unthinkable.
The last 200 years have been the real test.
A weak ummah then shattered by tests and fitness and innovations in every way at a
time when we are at our worst and our weakest.
And yet, you know, this um is amazing and it has in it people like you.
And uh we have got to bring it back to life in our hearts and to
take that gift to our friends and our neighbors and to people everywhere in the world.
That's what you have to devote your life to.
And may Allah give you long life.
And may he enable you to use your life really well no matter what you do.
Amen.